Now we're going to hop into the Lakehouse project.
If you don't already have it open, go ahead and do so.
What we're going to do is we're going to add some assets
into our project and explore some things
as far as transforms and moving them around.
So in order to add assets into a scene,
we'll get into the Lakehouse here in a second.
But as you can see, there are multiple things
you can select here within the library.
We have objects, vegetation, Megascans,
Adobe Substance 3D and Sketchfab,
as well as some characters and vehicles.
Now these are all animated in the yellow.
So those are ones that are nice
for when you want just like simple animations,
like cars will drive along a path.
We won't be discussing how to do that,
but that is in a later lesson.
Now the Sketchfab and the Adobe Substance 3D
are very important, including the Megascans.
The Sketchfab and the Adobe Substance,
especially the Adobe Substance 3D requires a login for that.
So you have to make sure you do have a subscription.
Otherwise this won't work for you,
but that's pretty much it.
Now we can also do what's called drag and drop
where you just literally grab an object as we see up here
and what we're gonna do and drag it into the object,
to our scene.
So let's go ahead and hop right into our Twinmotion scene
and we can go up here and type search.
I'm gonna type in knife
because I know the knife rack is inside the house.
And if you hit F as in Frank to frame it,
you will be inside the house.
So you don't have to worry about zooming in so closely.
And I'm gonna position myself here
and you can follow my little mouse button IDs right here.
It'll give you an idea of where to go.
Now we're gonna go in here into the objects
and then into the home and kitchen
and finally accessories.
And I just know this is where this is at
that I'm looking for.
I'm gonna look for that knife block.
So go ahead up here and type in knife block.
And you should see this little guy here.
And all you have to do is grab it
and position it here into the scene,
just like this, okay?
And it will drag it in.
Now you'll notice it snaps right to the top.
Now there are some cool ways.
Now you see how this turns orange?
I'm gonna zoom in a little bit.
This turns orange.
What this does is this allows you to snap along the edge.
Now you'll notice it just kind of floats
right along that plane.
It won't go any place else
as long as you have it there.
Now see the little globe here?
This enables you to snap wherever.
Obviously you don't want it to go on the side of a wall,
but that's the power of this
to say like for a picture, for example,
you could snap it to the wall.
But in this case, we're gonna go ahead
and snap it right to our surface here
and drag it along.
And then we're gonna rotate.
Now see how this turns into orange?
You can actually type in your values.
So let's just say you wanna do a 90 degree.
There, bam.
Or let's say, hey, maybe I wanted another 90 degrees
or 180.
You could type in 180.
And there we go.
It's kind of facing the direction that I wanted it.
Now, if you still feel like this isn't positioned
exactly where you would want it, that's okay.
Play around with that.
I'm also gonna have you play around
with to add some additional type of objects
if you want to into your kitchen.
I may not like where this is positioned.
I'm just gonna kind of leave it right here for now.
And that's it for that,
for as far as adding in anything else.
So let's hop right back into our PowerPoint here,
see the slides.
So we did cover all this
and you can replace other objects.
And there's some really cool things called configurations
where you could go through and swap out various chairs
to show your client or someone, a friend perhaps,
to show the different types of chairs that you can have.
Now, again, we're not covering that.
That's a little more advanced
for what we're covering today,
but this will work really well.
Now again, you can import multiple ways.
You can also import what's called the Datasmith plugin,
but that will be covered later
in our introduction to Twinmotion course.
So if you wish to learn more about that,
feel free to sign up for that class.
But otherwise it's pretty straightforward,
drag and drop, search and grab.
Now, because we have all these other available,
Megascans, Sketchfab, as well as the Adobe Substance 3D,
you can imagine there are hundreds of thousands
of assets available to bring in.
So be creative,
drag more things into your kitchen scene
and kind of play around with that.
Now again, here's what we did with N.
We talked about how the orange area,
you could slide along the surface
as well as the little sphere
allows you to snap to other areas.
You can also rotate using that little rotation
where it turns orange.
That means that's what axis it's in.
So in this case, it was on the Y
and the Z would be here
and that would just cause it to rotate or scale.
As you can see here,
you can do the same thing with anything on the outside.
So go ahead and play around with that.
Now in our next video,
we're gonna cover how to work with materials.
So we'll just go a little early briefly over that,
but here we go.
Let's get started.